[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à séoul
c'est qui ce mec à côté moi c'est les
eaux du café du geek
léo il me fait venir à séoul présenté
libre à une personne quand on était au
csa vegas pour aller rencontrer
l'écosystème des start up bourré de
hockey well hockey local local de corée
donc voilà donc là on à séoul on va
partir découvrir des start up on va les
bords des startups à noter les start up
qui font pitch est devant nous voilà on
va avoir un peu de tout ça va être cool
et là on est dans un hôtel qui est
vachement sympa à séoul en les truies
alors je vous dis tout de suite on a de
lire les mémoires on partage pas le même
les voilà en tout cas c'est cool plutôt
ça fait deux jours à séoul statu quo
maintenant une semaine mais renée à
quang nam nam style dance j'ai honte
pour cette séquence j'en ai fait un peu
bizarre ici à spa s'il vous connaissez
la vie on a cette espèce de truc un peu
et ça a marché
si je mets pourquoi tu peux te nettoyer
l'anus tu te mets toi l'anus avec ça way
attendu mais du poids sur les choses
est-ce que ça a opéré quelques heures
mardi dont quatre en importe quoi avec
quelques chansons mais des trucs là pas
un truc qui vient te nettoyer la plage
et qui sort d'un petit j'ai qui sort et
c'est sympa je trouve que ça quand même
relativement bizarre mais c'est
peut-être 13 yannick c'est très commun
ici c'est très commun ici dans le temps
et quand même un peu à certains ça s'est
un peu levé quand même là il a bien plu
comme bosser ces immeubles qui se
construisent comme ça la vague une
colline derrière la pollution devrait
l'avoir normand
[Musique]
dans notre cas très étranges tissés les
passages piétons que vous avez de voir
ça que ma voix pour avancer ça c'est la
voix des autres
pour lui si parfois je le respecte mais
normalement vous devez pas vous rentrez
dans son travers petite vache rouge avec
eux en coréen samsung fait des voitures
ça nous sommes automobile logo c'est
quoi ces femmes sous le renouveau
c'est une renault renault samsung motors
s comprend mieux la profession
totalement bagnols ici il faut à peine
les building pour le bas
demandez à la pollution la douce à des
voitures mais on est perdu là je sais
pas du tout où on va tous nous prend des
escalators qui tout à l'heure tu es au
courant que l'on sait pas où et pourquoi
tu vas là-bas est écrit nulle part que
c'est l'argent les deux tu vois des gens
suivent par conséquent corps et on sait
que de toute façon c'est sûr ça a été
écrit encore et encore et on est perdu
mais je confirme on est perdu on est
quand même bien perdu que deux classes
vous emmène au mic c'est made in korea
c'est un salon qui se tient à séoul
l'idée en gros ça doit être une start-up
coréenne qui vont venir pitcher mais des
notes on fait tout ça on rencontre plein
de mots en fins auxquelles vachement
intéressant donc la géantiste en instant
de logoté monsieur greu et puis il ya
pas mal de monde derrière vous avez une
compagnie russe là bas sont des
américains
il ya mon pote léo qui est jeune c'est
joue là bas puis on va rencontrer les
synthés toute la journée mettre des
notes je sais que vous les présenter et
puis on va découvrir on peut voir ce qui
se passe du côté de la corée
première star groupe qui nous présente
alors c'est une solution pour bien
cuisiner menu cuisine et vous avez
d'espèces de sachiez avec différents
vous miles product cinquième des jo
ça c'est une boîte qui pourrait vous
sauver la vie en fait lorsque vous
n'avez pas le temps de vous brosser les
dents je n'ai pas de travail ou en
voyage pour gagner bien vous avez cette
petite poudre en sachet l'idée c'est que
vous le prenez vous laisser la peau 10
20 secondes dans votre bouche et il y a
principe actif en intérieur qui va venir
rotules et bactéries intérieur de votre
bouche sa porte et chose à un gain en
termes d'hygiène
là vous avez la liste ségo là bas est en
fait vous enlevez les trucs et afat avec
ça vous fabriquez un petit objet en
trois dimensions un petit lapin c'est un
complément alimentaire pour chiens à
base de ces oeufs j-100 sauvages parce
qu'ils vous connaissez c'est une racine
en fait qui a priori est vachement cool
un espèce de truc sur lequel vous bougez
et toi ok quand je demande avant il
saute et après jeudi via droite à gauche
enfin un truc assez bon en fait vous
faites de la la gamification sur le
sport l'idée est plutôt bonne vous
faites du sport en jouant mais à la fin
vous récupérez la donne et voyez le
nombre de calories vous avez brûlé y
voyez vous en êtes
il ya des applications c'est bon je vous
présente une ampoule connecteurs pas été
assez marrant c'est un peu un concurrent
coréen de philips ou sauf qu'au lieu de
vous connecter en wifi ce que vous
auriez g et philippe ue à vous connecter
en bluetooth directement de smartphones
et c'est marrant parce que vous
vous appliquez sur la par exemple le
scanning plage et la couleur de l'eau
jusqu'à une double je gagnais du rouge
safran rouge comme ce thème du bleu
touquet du touquet ac ou alors vous
pouvez programmer sa régie à la mener
cette époque ça c'est assez cool parce
que vous avez de l'anc où l'on peut
classer ou quoi en connectés plein il
avait deux lampes ou sur support tsahal
a réalisé que d'un big enfin un truc
assez marrant c'est deux fois moins cher
que je tapais puis les few racing
technologies made in power
c'est après vous utilisez un camping
vous mettez la couleur vous voulez vous
le mettez comme ça il s'accroche pour
une petite ampoule d'appoint vous pouvez
l'utiliser en à la fin il ya pas mal de
choses à faire avec sa série gaudreault
pas ce que vous en pensez en vain ce que
vous pensez qu'un objet comme ça ça
pourrait vous tenter d'avoir une espèce
donc plus connecte en bluetooth
directement ya pas mal de cadres usage
plutôt cool
là on a un bouquin qui est intéressant
c'est tout pour les enfants en fait vous
avez un livre vous avez tous types de
supports petit livre en livre 5,70 de 5
à 10 ans en haut vous allez avoir une
tablette vous allez scanner l'intérieur
des pages et ça vous donner du contenu
pour réalité augmentée en fait des trucs
qui vachement cool parce que moi je
prends mon fils par exemple elliott ya
cinq ans il sait pas lire
il peut prendre sa tablette de prendre
son livre qui peut venir scanner ça va
donner vie à ses personnages
alors il faut toujours papa ou maman qui
l'utilisent l'histoire concerne est
relativement compliqué mais pour
permettre de découvrir dans
l'interaction trouve ça vraiment cool
c'est un papier vous utilisez vous
mettez au fond de votre poêle en fait
c'est du petit kiff abaisse de charbon
sans papiers d'origine coréenne et
l'idée c'est que ça va venir régulier
température il va s'hydrater parce qu'il
va recueillir les graisses donc en gros
ça va empêcher que
de salir votre poêle tout simplement et
ça va redistribuer après les graisses
dans sa valise raté ce que vous allez
faire cuire notamment au micro pour le
texas assèche j'avais un petit clavier
comme ça qui va se connecte en bluetooth
sa salle gré du sourire donc je peux
naviguer
j'ai ma petite souris qui se déplace et
ça c'est une bonne idée quand tous ceux
qui ont des réponses ou des tablettes ou
même avec un smartphone mais qui veulent
pas s'embêter bien vous utilisez ça
comme un petit clavier et ça c'est
vraiment pathétique de la fabrique des
découverts en cuivre à tous qui est
assez marrant c'est que le cube
effectivement enfin particulièrement
partout et là vous avez des fourchettes
isama ouvrir le goulet si vous vous
intéressez aux questions de la beauté
produits de si vous avez des produits de
corée qui sont alors bon c'est plus
j'avais des produits pour la peau pour
la beauté pour faire une petite beauté
pour votre courrier la salle est pour
une banque qui s'appelle sandmann alors
l'idée en fait c'est ils ont créé une
solution qui permet de lutter contre
alzheimer
c'est une solution qui est intéressant
c'est un logiciel pas que vous avez
plein de jeux avec man niveau difficulté
alors a tout écrit encore rien je ne
sais absolument pas lié vous avez plein
de jeux différents
l'idée c'est que ça va venir faire une
gymnastique mentale pour vous permettre
à toutes les personnes qui sont
injustement atteinte d'alzheimer et pour
s'entraîner
je dirais vitamines et le cerveau et
pouvoir reculer au maximum l'évolution
de la maladie
[Musique]
à quelle journée
bon pas mal découverte de plein de start
up and ecosystem coréens alors vous avez
vu on n'est pas du tout dans la tête là
mais clairement pas du tout par contre
c'est plutôt cool plus en plus au tac un
peu de texte c'est cool a besoin de
temps en tête et c'est ça j'ai récupéré
la ces se produit là c'est le clavier
connectés bluetooth il se peut qu'on il
se peut qu'on en parle c'est pas sûr
mais sinon qu'on en parle il est venu
voir tout le monde je pense me maesa
faire son business
bon j'en ai vu oui en tout cas truc
vachement cool événement sympa pour
découvrir un peu ce qui se passe du côté
de la corée au niveau des écosystèmes
start up plutôt bonne découvert plutôt
très sympa là on a 45 minutes pour se
reposer ce clairement faire une sieste
puisque nous empêcher de dormir le soir
incroyable ce mec il y ait besoin de
faire une sieste
bref se reposer se faire beau fabriquer
les chaussures et puis sortir ce sont
des grosses ong ces deux films avec le
smartphone à un gros ce soir est donc là
soit ça continue et puis à la suite du
conflit de la soirée je pense que ça va
être n'importe quoi soit on arrête là
parce que je vais voyager pas filmer que
c'était n'importe quoi en gros je crois
mais j'en ai marre iphone d'un
smartphone mais qu'on va baisser en
qualité mais on va monter on va monter
en qualité concrète et de contenu
n'importe pas catégorie n'importe quoi
bref bisous merci hein et puis si on
voit dans trente secondes c'est plutôt
cool
vous allez bientôt
ce jour
tu
hu
ouais